I have been told by multiple local Malaysians
that when they travel outside of their home
country, it's the food they miss more than
anything, even more than their family.
Nasi lemak, which literally translates to
fatty rice, is one of the ultimate examples
why.
Near Dang Wangi LRT station in Kuala Lumpur,
Malaysia, is a little heavenly food stall,
a gem culinary contribution to the world,
RA nasi lemak.
To my overjoy, RA was set up as a welcoming
self service buffet, meaning self control
was hardly an option.
Though I wanted to consume everything the
popular eatery had on display, it would simply
be impossible on a single plate, and so I
chose as much as I could.
It's called nasi lemak, and it's a coconut
infused steamed rice, with a bunch of different
toppings on top.
I'm ecstatic to start digging in here.
First, I don't even know where to begin but.
I got some squid which is stewed in sambal,
red chili curry and a little bit of vegetables.
I'm going to try the squid first.
It's a little bit sweet, spicy, that is exceptional,
and then a stewed piece of chicken, rendang,
and it's stewed in coconut milk and spices
and that's also on top of my rice.
Let me grab a piece of the chicken.
That is approaching perfection on
a plate.
That was stunning, I don't even want to do
anything for the rest of the day, I just want
to relax and sip on tea.